-The President has been accused
of working for
a foreign government
while our own government
remains shut down.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The government shutdown
is now the longest in history,
with no end in sight.
In fact, today the President
stopped by reporters
to let them know he was
carrying on with other business,
like a speech
to a group of farmers.
-I'll be going to New Orleans
right now.
I'm going to be speaking
in front of our great farmers.
-Okay, got it.
He's on his way to New Orleans.
Or at least I think he is,
because this morning
one of Trump's
other personalities tweeted,
"Getting ready to address the
farm convention in Nashville."
Hey, at least
it started with an "N."
And in fairness to Trump,
it was only his fourth guess.
[ Laughter ]
So while Trump
was off to New Orleans,
or as he calls it,
the home of country music,
the effects of the shutdown
were having
very real consequences
for millions of people.
For example, over the weekend,
federal employees
showed up to food banks
in the hundreds.
But that's not the food
Trump was concerned with today.
He was much more concerned
with the food he'll be serving
at the White House
for a ceremony
with the college-football
championship team from Clemson,
as he explained to reporters.
-The Clemson championship team,
the national championship team,
will be coming tonight.
It will be exciting.
Very great team.
An unbelievable team.
They'll be coming tonight.
And I think we're going to serve
McDonald's, Wendy's,
and Burger Kings
with some pizza.
I really mean it.
It will be interesting.
And I would think
that's their favorite food.
-No, dude, I think
that's your favorite food.
He thinks he's being so sly.
"Normally, I would have a salad
for dinner on Monday,
but they told me
they only eat every fast food."
Also, can we go back to this?
-McDonald's, Wendy's, and
Burger Kings with some pizza.
-Why does he say "Burger Kings,"
plural?
Does he think
there's more than one?
"We will be having
all of the Burger Kings
over to the White House
for a summit on trade."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I think...
I think it's safe to say
that had he lost the election,
the Burger Kings would have been
the name of the food show
Trump hosted with Guy Fieri.
[ Laughter ]
Now, it is entirely possible
that Trump thought
shutting down the government
would make
the Russia investigation
just go away.
I'm sure his lawyers
told him that.
"You can't be arrested
by the government
if there is no government!"
But as we found out on Friday,
that is very much not the case.
In fact, we got one of
the biggest blockbusters yet.
-Breaking news tonight
from "The New York Times."
The FBI opened an inquiry
into whether President Trump
was secretly working
on behalf of Russia.
In the days after
President Trump fired
James B. Comey as FBI director,
law-enforcement officials
became so concerned
by the President's behavior
that they began investigating
whether he had been working
on behalf of Russia
against American interests.
-Wow.
The FBI was investigating
whether Trump was working
for the Russians.
I mean, what tipped them off?
Was it Trump's secret
meeting with the Russians
in the Oval Office,
his son's secret meeting
with Russians in Trump Tower,
his lawyer's secret deal to
build a Trump Tower in Moscow,
Jeff Session's secret meeting
with the Russian ambassador,
Jared Kushner's secret
back channel with the Kremlin,
Michael Flynn's secret
Erik Prince's secret
back channel with the Kremlin,
Paul Manafort sharing secret
polling data with the Russians,
his foreign policy
advisor's secret meeting
with the Russians,
the Russian hackers
who helped Trump win,
Trump asking the Russian hackers
to help him win,
or Vladimir Putin's smile
every time he sees Trump?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
That's the smile Putin gives
when someone says,
"We have captured James Bond."
[ Laughter ]
Trump has also met privately
with Putin multiple times,
and over the weekend,
"The Washington Post" reported
that Trump has gone to
extraordinary lengths to conceal
details of his conversations
with Putin,
including,
on at least one occasion,
taking possession of the notes
of his own interpreter.
Now, we don't know what
Trump did with those notes,
but we do know
that in her tell-all book,
former Trump aide Omarosa said
she saw Trump
trying to destroy evidence
by eating a piece of paper
in the Oval Office.
And if you forgot
that the President
was accused of eating paper
by his own aide,
take note of the fact that we
are living through a presidency
where that insane fact might
actually qualify as forgettable.
For every other president
before him, eating paper
would be number one on the list
of craziest [bleep] things,
but...
[ Cheers and applause ]
But for Trash Can Jones
over here,
it doesn't even crack
the top 100.
We for real have a president
who may one day say,
"If you want my notes,
you'll need a search warrant...
for my belly."
And, of course,
Trump wants to keep the details
of his conversation
with Putin secret.
Every time we find out
about a private conversation
he had with Putin, it turns out
he said something suspicious.
Like when Putin
won a rigged election
and Trump's aides wrote
in his briefings in all caps,
"DO NOT CONGRATULATE,"
and then Trump said this.
-I had a call
with President Putin
and congratulated him
on the victory.
-Now, in fairness to Trump,
he would have read the briefing,
but he was hungry.
[ Laughter ]
So the President
was being investigated
for possibly working
for a foreign government
and at the same time
he was shutting down
our own government.
If it feels to you like our
political system is in chaos
right now, you're not alone.
The only one who disagrees
is Trump himself,
and he made that clear
in a tweet over the weekend.
-"I just watched a fake reporter
from the Amazon
'Washington Post'
say the White House is chaotic.
There does not seem to be
a strategy for this shutdown.
There is no plan.
The fakes always like
talking chaos. There is none.
In fact, there's almost nobody
in the White House but me."
-What?!
Nothing is more chaotic
than a huge building
with only one person working.
That's why RadioShack
went out of business.
[ Laughter ]
So Trump says he's all alone
in the White House,
which leaves him plenty of time
to do important president stuff,
like call into Fox News
and scream a lot.
And that's what he did
on Saturday.
Fox host Jeanine Pirro started
by asking about the shutdown,
and right off the bat,
Trump told an obvious lie.
-You're sitting there
waiting for a deal.
The Democrats are not
sitting with you.
If this isn't an emergency,
I don't know what is.
-Well, I haven't actually left
the White House in months.
-What?!
We've seen you leave
the White House repeatedly.
Last week, you went
to the southern border,
and in December you visited
the troops in Iraq, remember?
You were wearing one of those
oversized jackets
you borrowed from Tom Brady?
[ Laughter ]
Why is your coat so big?
Are you sneaking immigrants
over the border?
[ Laughter ]
"We're almost --
We're almost back on the plane."
So, Trump claimed he hadn't left
the White House in months,
which led Pirro to grill him
with a series of super-tough
follow-up questions.
-Mr. President, when
are you gonna get out
of the White House?
I mean, Washington after a while
gets very depressing.
-Well, I love it.
-Mr. President, I really hope
you get out of the White House.
I really do.
I think you deserve a vacation.
-Wow, Jeanine. That's a real
hard-hitting question.
Just because you're shouting,
it doesn't mean
you're grilling him.
"You deserve a vacation!
And I'll tell you another thing!
You're a handsome good boy!
And your skin's a normal color!"
[ Laughter ]
Then Pirro finally got to
the news of the weekend --
the FBI's investigation
into Trump.
She asked Trump point-blank if
he had ever worked for Russia.
And, now, any normal person
in this situation would say,
"No, of course not.
That's insane."
That is not how Trump responded.
His entire uninterrupted answer
to that question
took almost two minutes.
-Are you now or have you ever
worked for Russia,
Mr. President?
-I think it's the most insulting
thing I've ever been asked.
I think it's the most insulting
article I've ever had written.
You know, I fired James Comey.
I call him Lyin' James Comey.
Andrew McCabe, Peter Strzok,
his lover, Lisa Page.
They did it.
I've been tougher on Russia
than anybody else, any other --
probably any other president,
period.
I think it was a great insult,
and "The New York Times"
is a disaster as a paper.
They've gone so far that people
that were necessary believers
are now big believers,
because they said that was
a step too far.
They really are a disaster
of a newspaper.
-Not once in that entire answer
did he say the word "no."
I mean, that's like
if your wife asks you,
"Are you sleeping with Susan?"
And you said...
-I think it's the most insulting
thing I've ever been asked.
-So, after dodging
the question on Saturday,
Trump tried to rectify
the situation today
by stopping by
the throng of reporters
gathered on the White House lawn
for his usual
chopper-adjacent Q&A,
and they asked Trump
for a second time
whether he had ever worked
for Russia.
-I never worked for Russia,
and you know that answer
better than anybody.
I never worked for Russia.
Not only did I never work
for Russia,
I think it's a disgrace
that you even ask that question.
Because it's
a whole, big fat hoax.
-First of all, why does Trump
always choose venues
where he has to shout?
He only does interviews on the
phone or next to a helicopter.
If the news
gets any worse for him,
he's going to do his next
press conference on speakerphone
from a wind tunnel
at a performance of
the musical "Stomp."
[ Laughter ]
Can we go back to this
real quick?
-It's a whole, big fat hoax.
-Yeah, that's right.
It's a big, fat hoax.
You know, a hoax
that only eats...
-McDonald's, Wendy's, and
Burger Kings with some pizza.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪